vamos a ver esta vez vamos a escribir 59
puntos 2 % y buscaremos llevar esto
hacia un decimal
lo representaremos como un decimal es
importante que recordemos que 59.2 por
ciento significa por ciento
por cada 100 por ciento lo que significa
59.2 d
de cada 100
esto qué significa esto también podemos
verlo como 59.2 entre 100 y con eso nos
resulta mucho más sencillo pensar
entonces en 59.2 entre 100
queremos al tener esta división lo que
podemos hacer en este caso es si
nosotros dividimos entre 10
recorreríamos el punto decimal hacia la
izquierda pero no estamos dividiendo
entre 10 estamos dividiendo entre 100
así es que volveremos a dividir entre 10
y de esta manera si dividimos dos veces
entre 10 estamos dividiendo entre 100 y
el punto decimal el cual estaba aquí
justo después del 59 ahora dividido
entre 100 se encuentra antes del 59 y
sería entonces 0.50 y 92 y así de rápido
podemos tener nuestra respuesta una
forma más en la que podemos pensarlo así
tenemos este 59.2 por ciento y lo vamos
a convertir a decimal dividiremos entre
10 y entre 100 para recorrer el punto
decimal y así tener punto 59 2 espero
haber sido clara y nos vemos en otro
vídeo